I tell you to present the next Awards I
want to explain one thing before we
tried to get Frankie to come out here
and sing from here to eternity but I
think but people are doing don't know
him too well but the people that do or
understand because this man has always
been a perfectionist he's a great guy
and a wonderful singer but now to
present the next Awards we have a real
Triple Threat Music Maker an ace
songwriter top producer musicals and
also won an Academy Award winner himself
I this is the wonderful mr. Arthur
freeze
anomalies for the best scoring of a
musical picture include eight off dice
for the bandwagon metal glottal mayor
ray hind are for calamity jane Warner
Brothers Alfred Newman for call me madam
20th Century Fox Fredrick Hollander and
Morris stola for the five thousand
fingers of dr. T Stanley Kramer Columbia
and Andre Previn and saw chaplain for
Kiss Me Kate metro-goldwyn-mayer the
envelope please the winner is Alfred
Newman for call me Madame
I'm accepting this for Alfred Norman I'm
Sol Siegel
nominated for the best musical score of
a dramatic or comedy picture are you go
Frida offer above and beyond
metro-goldwyn-mayer Morris stole off and
George Dunning premiered to Eternity
Columbia Nicholas Rosa Julius Caesar
metro-goldwyn-mayer run is law caper
Lily metro-goldwyn-mayer Louis Forbes
for this is Cinerama Cinerama
productions the winner the winner is
Bronislaw table for Lally
thank you very much thank you
here are the nominees for the best song
first used in an ineligible production
the moon is blue Preminger Herbert
production the United Artists music
official Berg Gilbert lyrics
Sylvia find my flaming heart for a
small-town girl metro-goldwyn-mayer
music Nicholas Brodsky lyrics Leo Robin
Sadie Thompson song blue Pacific blues
from miss Sadie Thompson Beckworth
columbia music lester lyrics ned
washington secret love from Calamity
Jane
Warner Brothers music Sammy fain lyrics
Paul Francis Webster that's amore from
the caddy
York Pictures Paramount music Harry
Warren lyrics Jack Brooks the envelope
please
Sammy fain and for sensitive to the
secret love
congratulations
and that wonderful this great pleasure I
don't know I don't know mr. Freed's
mentioned where the gentleman was that
accepted the award for mr. Newman that
was a wonderful producer man that I had
the pleasure of working with and call me
madam and I'm going to work with him in
a picture call no business like show
business mr. Sal Siegel